i
[Música]
según las últimas proyecciones de la
comisión económica para américa latina
honduras un país de un poco más de 9
millones de habitantes pasó de 5.2 a 5.5
millones de personas que viven bajo
condiciones de pobreza de acuerdo a
estas estadísticas la lista de países
latinoamericanos que viven en esta
condición la encabeza honduras con un
57.8 por ciento le sigue nicaragua con
un 55 puntos 7 por ciento y de los
países centroamericanos en el tercer
lugar está guatemala con un 50.9 por
ciento según la ong 2 de el impacto de
la pandemia además la situación del
cambio climático agravada por el embate
de los huracanes esta y otra a finales
del año pasado la improvisación con que
se manejan las crisis y además los altos
niveles de corrupción ha provocado que
el país retroceda
en su desarrollo además de eso el
producto interno bruto podría caer un 10
por ciento en este país centroamericano
[Música]
la pobreza y la pobreza extrema pudieron
haber sido peores durante la pandemia
ese es uno de los hallazgos más
importantes del último informe de la
cepal el organismo dijo que la
diferencia en la marcaron las ayudas
estatales en américa latina y el caribe
en colombia la pobreza extrema para 2020
se estimaba en un 19% pero los dineros a
los más vulnerables ayudaron a que esta
cifra fuera de 16 9% las ayudas también
contribuyeron a que hubiera un punto
porcentual menos de pobreza pero los
beneficios oficiales no fueron
suficientes al igual que en todos los
países la pobreza aumentó en colombia
durante la pandemia la diferencia es que
esta nación es donde hay mayor
porcentaje de pobreza en toda sudamérica
el confinamiento golpeó particularmente
el desempleo de las mujeres las
colombianas que quedaron sin trabajo son
casi el doble que los hombres que
perdieron sus empleos esta brecha entre
hombres y mujeres sólo se vio en
colombia costa rica y perú
[Música]
la pandemia ha impactado con dureza a la
economía boliviana tal es así que un
informe de la cepal ha establecido que
se ha incrementado la pobreza y la
pobreza extrema en bolivia durante el
año 2020 en el año 2019 la pobreza en
general superaba el 30% y la pobreza
extrema estaba por encima del 12% sin
embargo el año 2020 esta situación ha
empeorado pues la pobreza en general ha
estado próxima al 40% y la pobreza
extrema ha estado entre el 14 y el 17
por ciento dependiendo de si hubo o no
transferencias económicas a la gente hay
que recordar que el gobierno transitorio
repartió bonos a la gente más necesitada
por ejemplo hubo un bono para la salud
otro para la familia y un bono universal
para todos aquellos que no recibían
ingresos durante la cuarentena la
principal causa de esta situación tiene
que ver con la falta de empleo el
instituto nacional de estadísticas
estableció a mitad del año pasado que el
desempleo había superado el 11 por
ciento un porcentaje que ha ido
reduciendo paulatinamente
[Música]